[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle ivananta je suis
vien et je suististe bonjour je
m'appelle je suis japonaise je fais du
saxophone je m'appelle Adriana je joue
le viel baroque je viens de la
[Musique]
Suède étudiants viennent du monde entier
et ils viennent pour devenir musicien
professionnel aujourd'hui dans ce nouvel
épisode de la chronique éducation je
vais vous faire découvrir une formation
sur la musique quand chanter sous sa
douche ou jouer à la guitare dans sa
chambre ne suffit plus on peut opter
pour le Master musique interprétation et
patrimoine délivré par les universités
de versaill saintquanttin en Yveline et
de Paris Saclay mais alors qu'est-ce
qu'on y apprend c'est ce qu'on va voir
dans un
[Musique]
instant le master musique Inter
interprétation et patrimoine forment les
musiciens interprètes qu'il soi
instrumentiste ou chanteur lyrique et
cette formation elle apporte des
compétences en gestion notamment pour
développer des projets artistiques et le
parcours est coopéré notamment par les
conservatoirs de Versailles Grand Parc
et d'Orsay et également par l'École
Normale de Musique de Paris alors cette
promotion se compose de 24 étudiants ils
sont 12 en master 1 et 12 ans Master 2
et ils sont tous étrangers et puis à la
suite de cette formation on peut devenir
musicien profession
directeur de structure artistique ou
encore médiateur culturel alors on a été
interviewé Christophe draver qui est
directeur adjoint du Conservatoire
Régional de Versailles et nous en dit
plus sur la formation et sur les enjeux
du secteur on
écoute l'idée de cette UE c'est de
pouvoir rencontrer justement des
intervenants extérieurs qu'il soient
régisseurs artistes déjà en freelance
dans des formation spécifique directeur
d'une scène nationale donc cette UE se
fait en partenariat avec la scène
nationale de 50 le théâtre et qu'il
puisse être immergé pendant tout un
semestre dans le monde professionnel
tout l'enjeu c'est de pouvoir comprendre
qu'on peut mener son propre projet un
projet personnel c'est développer sa
propre esthétique ou ses propres envies
en être moteur créateur innovateur donc
ce sont des enjeux plus difficiles et ça
se prépare justement lorsqu'on est dans
dans son cadre d'étude et on a également
été rencontré Adriana qui est étudiante
en Master 2 et guusel une ancienne
étudiante et toutes les les deux nous
parlent de la formation et de leur
projets futur regardez déjà je trouve
que les enseignants sont superbes donc
c'est souvent c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi cette formation mais aussi je
trouve que ici on est donné les la
contexte pourquoi on fait de la musique
aussi comment on
peut s'intégrer dehors de l'école en
fait et ça c'est très important
j'aimerais faire des projets avec des
orchestres notamment des orchestres Baro
musque avec musique ancienne mais aussi
enseigner je trouve que c'est ça fait
partie de la vie et c'est important
aussi moi je voudrais jouer bien sûr
avec mes amis faire des ensembles de
musique de chambre et aussi je voudrais
essayer de créer les projets
musical maintenant ça m'intéresse de
faire les projets pour les pour les
enfants on n pas beaucoup de temps
peut-être temps mais les moyens pour
aller à la Philharmonie au
concert chaque soir je sais pas oui et
juste pour venir une fois et jouer
pendant une journée je pense que c'est
intéressant pour les étudiants juste
après les cours aller voir aller écouter
la musique montrer que nous sommes aussi
les étudiantes et nous jou la musique
classique c'est intéressant c'est pas
que pour
les on peut dire les vieux oui c'est
donc c'est pour tous les tous les âges
et voilà si ces témoignages vous ont
donné envie sachez que vous pouvez vous
inscrire sur le site de l'université
Paris sa clé attention tout de même les
admissions sont très sélectives il faut
déjà être diplômé de l'enseignement
supérieur il y a également un concours
d'entrée allez on se quitte sur une note
de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
musique
[Musique]